[Music]
we ended the previous video with a
question why does methane give us a blue
flame without any soot and why does wood
burned with a yellow flame with soot let
us try finding out the answers there are
two important perspectives here one is
about what compound is undergoing
combustion and the other is the way in
which the burning process takes place
let us talk about the first case when I
say what compound undergoes combustion
we would say hydrocarbon that's correct
and obvious - but here we're trying to
talk about the type of hydrocarbon that
means whether it's a saturated or an
unsaturated hydrocarbon saturated
hydrocarbons have a single covalent bond
between all the carbon atoms on the
other hand unsaturated hydrocarbons have
at least one double or triple bond
between the carbon atoms we know that
methane is a saturated hydrocarbon and
what type of flame is seen on burning
methane yes it's clear blue coloured
flame so are we trying to say that
saturated hydrocarbons burn with a clear
blue flame yes and why is that
combustion is a process in which the
oxygen atoms break through the carbon
bonds that means newer bonds will be
formed along with the breaking of older
ones as a result carbon dioxide and
water are formed along with energy
liberation so in case of saturated
hydrocarbon the oxygen atoms are able to
break the bonds very easily that is
because there are only single bonds that
exist however in case of unsaturated
hydrocarbons the same number of oxygen
atoms will be unable to break the carbon
bonds easily it's because the efforts
needed for breaking double or triple
bonds will be greater so it is the
presence of single or double and triple
bonds between the carbon units that
result in blue or yellow flames
respectively now let us talk about the
next perspective what type of combustion
is taking place
in the same example that we mentioned a
while ago if you notice I said that same
amount of oxygen is insufficient to
break the double and triple bonds
remember that means the same number of
oxygen atoms that were used to break
bonds in the saturated compound proof
insufficient for breaking the bonds in
the unsaturated one this clearly
indicates that the oxidation process is
not completed wait what is oxidation by
the way well here the term refers to the
burning of the compound in the presence
of oxygen so in the case where the
oxidation of the hydrocarbon is not
completed it will give us a yellow
flame but our second example was that of
burning wood so what is the connection
between these points
well wood burns very rapidly that means
the upper surface in contact with air
burns too quickly as a result it becomes
difficult for oxygen to reach the deeper
layers and thus incomplete combustion
results in yellow flame with soot let me
give you another example have you ever
noticed the gas burners in kitchens they
usually burn with a clean blue flame but
as the burners get older the gas starts
burning with a yellow flame not only
this it also gives out thick black soot
which spoils the bottom of the vessel
have you ever wondered why this happens
yes the only answer for this is the
complete and the incomplete combustion
process when the gas burner gets old its
air holes get clogged as a result all
the oxygen needed to burn the fuel does
not reach it that is the reason why we
start getting yellow flames it
clearly indicates inefficient use of
fuel to conclude this let us review the
reasons for obtaining blue and yellow
flames again when do we obtain a blue
clear flame yes we obtain it either when
a saturated hydrocarbon is burnt or when
there is complete combustion of the
compound in contrast to this a yellow
flame with soot is obtained when the
hydrocarbons are on
saturated or when there is incomplete
combustion of the compound now this was
about the combustion reaction of
hydrocarbons can you tell me the next
one from our list yes it's the oxidation
reaction let us learn more about it in
the upcoming videos
[Music]
you